[Music]
[Applause]
give me
[Music]
that so it should probably surprise
absolutely nobody that POI dance has
been a major theme in my flow for the
past couple years
but there was one specific thing that
has kind of made it a challenge through
that time and I'd like to talk a little
bit about that in this video
specifically the topic of suspensions
and why people who are used to having
access to them might have some problems
when they switch over to POI now all
that said
um today is a day I've been waiting for
a long time it is the reopening of the
air and space museum down in the
National Mall and I have timed entry
tickets to go check it out I'm going to
share this with you so come and walk
with me as we talk about this yeah drix
here from Drex Factor POI sharing with
you the love of poi spinning and flow
Arts to benefit your body and brain and
today we're talking about POI dancing
and specifically how those pesky
suspensions can be figured out even in
the POI world but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinski and
Becca becklinen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission y'all I am running late here
I'm hoping that they're not going to
mess with me showing up a little bit
later than what my entry pass is there
for but uh yeah everybody keep your
fingers crossed for me uh interesting
incidentally if anybody's curious about
this so uh they shut down a big part of
the air and space museum on the National
Mall a couple years ago to basically
renovate it and expand the space and
change a bunch of the exhibits it was
it had a small portion that was open
um for the past couple years including
uh during the pandemic and now they are
reopening big portions of that museum
that they have been renovating and today
is literally the first time the general
public has seen any of these new parts
of the museum so I'm really really
excited to check this out okay so all
that said
um let's talk a little bit about
suspensions and what they have to do
with poi
show
um when I first started learning how to
dance more than a decade ago
um it was like one of the most difficult
things I have ever tried to do in my
adult life I had no background or
context for it I'd never done dance
growing up
um and let's just say that starting it
as a six foot tall at the time like 29
year old man was definitely not the
place on the learning curve that I
wanted to be but try I did nonetheless
and as I was learning how to dance there
was a piece of that puzzle that jumped
out at me as being somewhat confusing
and that was the capacity
to be able to um
as you were dancing just like stop
whatever you were doing and hang out
there in a shape for a moment in the
Dance World this is referred to as doing
a suspension and it's something that
kind of draws out tension and
performances and it's a pretty integral
tool for choreographing to like just
about anything you can think of and of
course as I'm going out here to record
there's a massive freight train going
down the tracks that that that will have
no impact on the audio whatsoever I bet
okay so here's the thing that is kind of
unique about POI as a flow prop that a
lot of other props don't have in common
with it and that is that you have to
keep POI moving more or less in order to
get it to do anything that is you have
to keep importing energy into it in
order to keep it swinging and it is
very very very clear when that flow of
energy
stops right it's either the POI just
kind of like hang limp and unused for a
moment or you know uh you wind up at a
point where whatever the POI was doing
just a second ago just abruptly stops
and it really sticks out and uh doesn't
look very good so a lot of the people
that I know who were dancers before they
got into flow Arts tend to favor static
props that is props that do not have
flexible components things like stabs
fans or Triads because well they can
take those suspensions any old time they
like
and it's long been a problem for me
figuring out like is this a tool that we
can get to work with poi
or is this just a weird incompatibility
between the traditional dance world and
the koi world and you know the funny
thing is
I actually have found some solutions for
suspensions that do work with POI there
are not many of them
but they do exist and goodness do they
ever pack a punch but more on that in a
moment because again I am up against the
clock and I gotta go bike down to the
metro station so I'll see you down there
foreign
[Music]
well it is just past 3 30 here and
usually it takes around 30 to 40 minutes
to get down to the National Mall so keep
the fingers crossed for me out there
friends yeah I'm going to mask up and
get on the Metro here
[Music]
all right so I just got off the Metro it
is five after four eek uh so I gotta get
across the mall in order to get to the
museum I'm just gonna rent another bike
to do that
um everybody keep your fingers crossed
here I hope they'll still take my ticket
[Music]
well I gotta say that was pretty cool
they only had like half of the museum
reopened I think they're still working
on renovating the other half but yeah
what I got to see I really enjoyed I'm
glad I got to catch this on the day that
reopened pretty rad and I'm glad that
the weather is so good out so out
let's go talk some turkey about dance
shall we
all right
so
ears I have found what I would say are
they a small list of pretty reliable
techniques that help to uh to make those
suspensions happen
um some of them actually have been
suggested by other artists and some of
them are kind of my own discoveries but
uh yeah let's roll through them so I can
give you some examples of this in action
so first up there is a method that has
long been championed by Nick Woolsey
which basically amounts to freezing the
body in different positions and just
keeping the POI moving in static spin
depending upon your proficiency keeping
the POI spinning at different places
around your body you may find that this
works really well for you
um I find that the utility of this can
be a little bit limited because as soon
as you do not have both of your feet
planted on the ground all of a sudden
you find that the movement necessary to
keep those POI going can sometimes mess
with your balance now that said if
you're in a pose where you have both
feet connected to the ground hey why not
this is definitely an option that works
option number two is stalls now I kind
of feel like this is cheating in some
ways because you know you're getting the
POI to stop moving so of course that's
going to be a point at which the body
and POI can both just hang out for a
second you also have to be kind of
careful with this one because uh
basically depending upon your timing and
Direction mode you wind up in places
where one or both POI are going to be
frozen up and it'll probably take
something like a g-pop to make sure that
they're both in the down position which
of course is the only one that is a
hundred percent stable when dealing with
these kinds of suspensions this also
turns out to be one of those places
where doing stuff in together opposites
really excels it gives you access to be
able to always have the POI settle in a
downward Direction and that of course is
exactly what you want to see out of some
of these suspensions now next up we have
what's basically A variation on that
stall idea which is to use pendulum
stalls or more specifically if you feel
inclined vertical stacking in order to
find those suspensions I find honestly
the vertical stacking works really
really well for this because it kind of
lends itself to creating those
suspensions anyway every time you do the
stack there's something about the kind
of like locking element to this that I
think really fits incredibly well with
those suspensions so I'm actually kind
of a big fan of this one next up an old
favorite spiral wraps now spiral wraps
definitely have a leg up on some of the
other methods for doing this if for no
other reason then if you really get your
spiral wraps down you can freeze that
moment when the POI come together and
use that as a moment to build tension
which of course is the entire point of
doing a suspension in the first place
I use this frequently both in a
two-handed as well is a one-handed kind
of orientation and I just find that it's
a great way for me to find those moments
of stopping it's also a great way to if
I'm going to change plane or something
like that it all of these things are
great options and finally a newer option
one that I had actually completely
forgotten was on the table is one that
we get from the glow streaming world and
that is shotguns I've found that
shotguns are not only great for finding
ways to get into the suspensions that
I'm talking about in this video but also
they tend to allow for you to play
around with just moving while the POI
are frozen this is something that you
don't find with any of the other methods
for finding suspensions anything else if
you keep on moving with the possible
exceptions of the Spiral wrap you're
going to get the POI moving as well and
kind of defeat the purpose of the thing
and of course you can build up even more
tension As you move without the POI
moving so that when they do get moving
again it feels like something of a
release for the the audience yeah I'm
gonna say I'm a big fan of this so what
I'd like to do is I'd like to give you
all a little bit of footage of me using
all of these different techniques at
different points here so you can kind of
see the efficacy of them yeah
[Music]
happy
cool I hope you enjoyed getting to go on
this field trip with me as well as
checking out some solutions that I found
for making POI suspensions happen if you
got anything out of this video please
make sure to like share comment and
subscribe to help other people find it
and of course to help my channel grow
foreign
this video would not be possible we're
not for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the people listed down in the
description helped make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for your support
now if you out there watching are not
currently supporter and you would like
to become one you can do that by heading
on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards do that at the length
that I include down in the description
or the card that just popped up if you
are watching on YouTube and best of all
you will be supporting me in my mission
to bring POI and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you if you'd like to check out
some of my other videos pondering
Concepts in POI and flow Arts I will go
ahead and leave a link to a playlist of
said videos up here on screen as well as
a link to a video that the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you will like uh
based upon your past viewing habits so
check one or both out yeah awesome thank
you so much for watching uh make sure to
get out to flow today and I will see you
with a new video on Wednesday
peace